make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are back with
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers but we're gonna deviate here
for a second
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
cover uh the last tidbit of avengers
world i don't really plan on it uh and
the reason why
is some of you guys may recognize the
name avengers world right and that was
the name of the first video that we did
and the reason why is because the first
volume of hickman's avengers is called
avengers world but what this did is it
created a spin-off series that was
largely written by nick spencer
alongside jonathan hickman that focused
on the whole idea of like the avengers
engine right so like having avengers all
across the world it wasn't really my
thing
but by the time he got to the end it did
provide some context now this bit of a
discussion is going to provide context
to what we're talking about in relation
to like the cabal going awry
and like just wiping out other worlds
and taking taking like comfort in it
like enjoying the idea of what they're
doing
and how name war lost control and then
we'll jump back into the into the the
meat and potatoes of hickman's avengers
and new avengers so what this does is it
basically picks up what the fantastic
four
on earth four seven three eight five
three eight three but again this is just
alternate reality stuff right like
actually gabriel uh one of like a really
long time fan like that guy's cool
every time i went to new york comic con
we never happen to meet each other and
we need to
um i don't even know gabriel do you have
a rob core ring if you don't like
like you should have gotten one a long
time ago
yeah hit me up on twitter send me a dm
on twitter and i'll send you a uh also
new rod pool ring but nonetheless the
part of the story that we saw in the
last video
right when like thanos killed the x-men
gabriel that was an
alternate reality right so when you see
like thanos like from this point going
forward when you see thanos in the black
order like killing people on other
worlds that's that's an ultimate that's
alternate reality stuff right on that
particular world there weren't really
any superheroes except for the x-men
that seemed to be the case so uh this
takes place on an alternate reality as
well and and this
you know really seems to be a world
where there is nobody but the fantastic
four right it's really just these guys
and the fantastic four have like a great
huge army that kind of a thing but we
basically pick up in the middle of the
the fantastic forest army
going against the forces of the black
order and getting totally overrun right
i mean
it's not really even much of a fight
like these guys are just overrun and
completely obliterate now one thing to
understand here guys
is that this is one of those things
where the longer that thanos and his in
his black order and neymar out there in
the multiverse facing off
facing off against different worlds the
more capable they become
right because you start to notice
certain patterns yet when they go to any
one particular earth they're only ever
really going to face off against one of
a handful of forces right like some
alternate reality version of the
avengers some alternate reality version
of the x-men
or some alternate reality version of the
fantastic four and getting used to the
fantastic force powers getting used to
the abilities of the x-men getting used
to having face-off against the avengers
after a while it just kind of becomes
rinse and repeat and you know exactly
how to plan your attacks in order to win
and that's why they've proved themselves
in being so capable
and taking out all these various forces
because after a while it's really just
practice right it's just an exercise in
efficiency and killing and so this
basically leads to
to enable the submariner who's you know
seemingly on this throne of the
fantastic four right and he's basically
killed reed
susan shows up there again this
alternate reality susan shows up there
and is surprised to see that neymar is
there but with this neymar arriving here
you know he almost kind of tells susan
that he's still
as much in love with her as as as he
ever was and really more with the
concept of susan right with the idea of
susan storm and the reason why is he
kind of hits
at what hickman did during fantastic
four with uh with reed richards where
it's like every universe that they
travel to where they encounter a version
of susan she's as headstrong as any
other universal counterpart right
especially the main marvel universe
when you look at her she's one of these
characters where she's headstrong she's
stubborn in a lot of ways uh but she's
got it together and if there's any one
chick you want in your corner it's
definitely her right she's got it where
it counts her force fields can hold off
celestial power
different things like that she's by no
means someone to scoff at but where
neymar kind of comforts her and says hey
look you know does the best you can to
kind of ease your transition and helping
you understand there's nothing you can
do to save your world and your world is
going to be destroyed
ultimately she ends up being killed by
proxima midnight and approximately
midnight's like it's time to go
like we're here to kill a world there's
no time for sentimentality here right we
came here to kill a world
she's dead let's destroy the world let's
go right we're gonna call it a day and
that's exactly what the cabal do right
they set off the anti-matter bomb they
obliterate the world and they basically
leave now from here it transitions over
to a small little conversation
between neymar the submariner and uh and
and black swan and this you know where
you kind of have neymar who's sitting
here sort of kind of recalling these
memories of people who are like begging
for their lives and different things
like that the reality is that what
neymor signed on for
is more than he can handle and that's
one of the cool things here it really
shows us that where
jonathan hickman wrote namor submariner
in such a way to where he's like i will
do what needs to be done
if the rest of you illuminati won't and
that's why he formed the cabal
what it really shows is that neymar kind
of bit off more than he could chew that
namor thought he was ready to destroy
worlds he thought he was ready to do
what needs to be done
but at the end of the day the black swan
was right when they first met her at the
very beginning of hickman's avengers and
new avengers it basically robs you of
what makes you who you are it robs you
of your heroism it robs you of your
humanity
it forces you to do things that you
wouldn't do and you end up losing
yourself and that's exactly what's
happened with neymar
slowly and steadily he's been losing
himself in this time that he spent with
the cabal he's basically
surrounded by regret he's surrounded by
sadness and misery by knowing that there
are so many innocent lives out there
that perish
and he tries to justify it by saying
like i do what i do in the name of the
greater good in order to save my
universe but it doesn't assuage his
conscience it doesn't help him accept
the fact that billions and billions and
really even we're getting into the
trillions at this point of innocent
people
have perished at the hands of the cabal
that he created and has now lost control
of now in his conversation with the
black swan she tells him i can see the
chinks in your armor i can see that you
are basically showing weakness you're
regretting your choice to side with the
cabal you're regretting your choice to
make
it like you're regretting the decisions
that you've made and doing what has to
be done but understand
there's no place here for sentimentality
there's no place here for weakness now
this is really important here because
one of the things to understand is that
at this point in the story and hickman's
avengers and new avengers there's a lot
of things going on
in the collapse of the multiverse that
we still don't know right we don't know
who the ivory kings are we don't know
who raboom allah is right the person
that started the incursions in the first
place
we don't know the origin of the black
priest we don't know that kind of stuff
we know the origin of the map makers but
that's basically it there's a lot that
we don't understand and that was the
whole message of of black swan the great
wheel turns where boom allah will get
his due like verbuma law
will be satisfied in the destruction of
these worlds there's no room for
weakness here
understand you signed on for this and if
you don't believe that you can handle
this then we will kill you
right like we'll destroy you and and
we'll we'll continue on with what we
have to do
it's so interesting to have a guy who
sat down and said i do you know i'm
gonna do what i feel like i must do but
at the same time ends up regretting it
later on down the road only to find out
that those individuals who appeared to
be bloodlusted are actually picking up
where he left off
it's intriguing to see now this jumps to
an alternate reality where you have the
fantastic form right and this is earth
number two
eight seven a whole bunch of random
numbers anyway uh this is an alternate
reality here and what this shows and
it's kind of interesting we're not
giving a lot of context to this earth
we're just given
the fantastic form right so reed
richards is basically a farmer he's
still
you know an inventor he still creates
devices and he's got some pretty
advanced devices to help him
tend to the yard right because work
smart not hard right that's the best
thing to do but then he's suddenly met
by the arrival of neymar the submariner
and then you switch back to thanos and
company and what we end up having or
at least what we end up finding out here
is that namor had called them all
together for a meeting but when they
arrived there
namor is nowhere to be found and when
the question is asked where's neymar at
proxy midnight responds he apparently
took off to that earth 20 minutes ago
and that's when thanos starts to freak
out because it's like what's going on
here right like
what is happening here and so thanos
feels as though he's being made a fool
of black swan's
watching on realizing okay this is
probably the moment when namor is going
to fall and then once you end up having
thanos in this company showing up on
this world then neymar says well i
scouted this place out ahead of time
right
i scouted this place out so that you
know i could basically save you the
trouble he basically says like i've
taken care of the bomb i've taken care
of everything
we can just leave now right he like
namor tries to like shoo them off the
planet basically right he tries to get
them away
and initially thanos is like no you're
going to deny
the the cabal it's tribute and the
responsive namor is yes
and he punches the crap out of thanos
and so it's kind of a back and forth and
it's only really for a moment right it's
you know namor punching thanos getting a
couple licks in and then thanos
overpowers them quite readily and even
kind of makes this comment
i had forgotten like the thrill of a
capable adversary right i've forgotten
what it's like to face off against
somebody who was on my level in in
different ways
and so what he does is he actually tells
thanos what he did
and it's the coolest thing right because
he he asked him like where's the bomb
at right like give me the detonator and
the responsive namor is i don't have the
detonator i don't have it on me i
understand the nature of reed richards
and i understand the nature of susan
storm i fought beside them on my world
for years and years and years and this
alternate reality version of their
characters are the exact same they're
the exact same kind of people as the
people that we're used to and so i know
that if i go and talk to them and tell
them what's going on
they'll listen to reason and that's
exactly what he did he went and told
reed here's what's going on here's the
nature of the incursions this is a bomb
here that could destroy your world and
i'm asking you to destroy it
because it would save my world the
question you have to ask is are you
willing to make that sacrifice are you
willing to end your world for the
purpose of saving another and it's and
it's the ultimate notion it's the
ultimate
idea of like self-sacrifice right and
reed richards is a gu is the kind of guy
at least in this alternate reality
version that would seem to do it now it
seems to fly in the face
of everything that we know but then we
kind of get a little bit of exposition
here
right where namor kind of expands on
this and says it's not just about this
idea of sacrifice understand that if you
don't do this there is a fate worse than
death that's coming for you the cabal
will come here and they will destroy
everything you know and they won't do it
quickly they won't just annihilate you
they won't just
kill susan storm or anything like that
they'll take their time they'll make you
suffer they take enjoyment out of that
so i give you an option either you can
detonate this bomb and die quickly or
you can keep it you can you can hold on
to it you can wait for the cabal and you
can die slowly but ultimately there's
really no way for you to survive
this particular incident and so what
ends up happening is you find out that
this alternate reality version of read
has the detonator and that's when you
have that's when you have neymar
laughing at thanos and saying like this
is it
i knew it was going to end this way and
this alternate reality version of read
pulls the trigger and detonates this
anti-matter bomb and when it seems like
thanos and neymar and all of them are
going to die
they're suddenly whisked away right
they're basically they teleport back to
the necropolis back to their base of
operations
and that's when thanos tells neymar
understand if you believe that you're
leading this cabal
anymore you're not and if you ever
really believed you were leading it
you weren't the only thing that you were
leading is yourself down the path of
self lies
that's all you were doing right you were
leading yourself down this prim most
path
understand i am thanos the mad titan i
am no one's servant
no one rules me no one tells me what i
will do if i decide that i want to kill
you i will kill you and so he says
if you get in the way of this cabal
again i will kill you
i will i will kill you where you stand
right i will and i will snuff your life
out like that and ultimately you end up
having namor who basically acquiesces
and that's what we kind of pick up with
the idea
of namor seeking out doctor doom and
also telling the illuminati the cabal is
beyond my control right there they're
beyond my ability to manage and maintain
now from here we switch over to the
formation of the multiversal avengers
team and the funny thing about this
is that this is the plan of sunspot but
it's only one part of the plan right
sunspot's got a twofold plan here the
first
is to basically form his own avengers
team the multiversal avengers which will
go into the multiverse and then find the
source of the incursions but the second
thing that he puts into motion is a plan
to answer the question
what if we can't right like what if it
comes down to the fact that we have to
destroy our own world in order to
survive remember that's one of the
things that black swan talked about now
you know sunspot doesn't has never
really met black swan he probably
doesn't really know who she is
but it's one of these things where he's
intelligent enough to have figured it
out right black swan said early on
in jonathan hickman's avengers new
avengers that's in some alternate
reality earth that's what the
superheroes did
right because the earth was the
incursion point so if both earths crash
into each other then it'll lead to the
destruction of both universes
either that or one of the earth's has to
be destroyed for both universes to
survive what it led to is
some superheroes destroying their own
world right and evacuating as many
people off their earth as they could and
then taking up residence out in space
until they could find a new home and in
the process
obliterating their own earth right
basically you know keeping their
universe safe without any real home now
not everyone was saved and it was
actually beast it was hank mccoy who
came up with the idea on alternate
reality earth right it's kind of a crazy
thing but the multiversal avengers team
is is formed out of a couple different
scenarios right and that's what aim had
been working on
under the direction of sunspot over the
last eight months right before we picked
up with the
the eight month jump advanced idea
mechanics was just exploring the source
of the incursions they were using their
resources to to explore the multiverse
and find out why it was collapsing why
it was dying
once sunspot took over then sunspot had
a more directive approach and it was
let's create basically a kind of bridge
right let's create a teleportation
device
that can send our forces out into the
multiverse into different locations and
find out what's going on and so you end
up getting night masks star brand
hyperion
thor abyss and a whole bunch of ex
nihilos right a whole bunch of ex nahili
who were going out there and the reason
why the ex new healers are involved here
is that while they are
basically life creators at the end of
the day they exist to preserve life and
so if there is a force out there that's
ending life then by their own definition
they should fight it defeated and then
allow life to proliferate right so it's
really the most pure version of their
individual cause but you end up having
these guys basically walking through
this portal
traveling forward for the purpose of
exploring the multiverse and trying to
find out what happens next but here's an
important thing this is an exceedingly
important conversation here that when
you end up having sunspot having a
conversation
with thor the two of them start talking
it's one of these things where
he tells thor like sending them out
there into the multiverse that it feels
wrong
and where thor's like why like why why
and why does that feel wrong and he says
because i'm staying here and i'm trying
to find some way to
to keep our universe safe right whether
it means destroying our own world and
trying to find some means of surviving
out there in space as essentially
refugees i don't know but i feel like i
should be out there like i feel i should
be i should be going with all of you
guys and and you know trying to
save as many universes as i possibly can
but ultimately thor says
we don't know what's out there and your
mind is needed here your intelligence
your resources
they're needed here and it's one of the
things that sunspot knows as well it's
safer for him to stay here because
ultimately if it doesn't work if thor
and them go out there and there's
there's no solution to be found
then it's like okay then we can rely on
your plan but sunspot stops them and he
says
look man you have to understand
something like you understand what this
mission is
right and he's like there's no coming
back from this you guys are all going to
die out there like no matter what
happens
you guys are going to die if you find
the source of the incursions it's going
to be unlikely that you can stop it if
you come across the black priest
you're probably going to die if you come
across the ivory kings you're definitely
going to die who knows what you're going
to encounter but understand this is a
one-way mission there's no expectation
of you returning here and then thor
thor has like the best response ever he
says yes it is an
end but to die striking down the great
destroyer what would be better fitting
of somebody like me right i'm thor the
god of thunder
i will not die sleeping in my bed i will
not grow old and die of age
if i'm going to die i'm going to die in
the most honorable way
possible i'm going to die doing
everything i possibly can
to stop the incursions it's the most
thor response
that anybody could ever imagine but
here's the cool thing right here's the
here's the here well i'm not gonna do
any spoilers i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
spoil anything but i will say this
thor and hyperion end up having what's
probably the single
greatest moment in the history of marvel
comics
it is amazing and if you guys know what
i'm talking about you guys know what i'm
talking about like don't spoil it please
do not spoil it down in the comments but
it's amazing it's like it's it's like
the coolest lines
oh my god it's like my favorite moment
from the entirety of hickman's avengers
the new avengers run well almost
almost my favorite moment is the is what
what what hank him tells everybody right
when hank pym gets back
that's my favorite moment but that one
and the one that comes up in the next
video i've got so many favorite moments
right like when the illuminati set that
said that hologram you guys know you
guys you guys read the story you know
what i'm talking about like when the
illuminati create the hologram and
you've got like beast and
hulk playing chess dude it's like the
coolest thing ever like they start
talking mad trash
it's the funniest thing but yeah so so
anyway guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you